oh
i knew it i knew that was going to
happen
the whole episode i was waiting stop
enjoying this yes
who did this wait who is that who is huh
what what how how did
that yes of course that was outstanding
i feel so stupid for not having seen
that coming wow
i i saw someone say that and i thought
that's ridiculous and of course that's
what the truth is
yes oh man that's awesome welcome back
to new rockstars and the breakdown of
the boys
season 2 episode 8 aka the season finale
what i know i'm tommy bechtold and this
is the boys underground boys only this
week
we told marina get out of here and get
surgery
uh and she did she elected to uh hip
surgery we wish her speedy recovery we
want her to get better very soon because
we need her
anyway this is the boys underground the
after show that's so much fun you'll do
anything short of murdering your own
mother to watch it
joining me today in the boys underground
is my number one boy sharing his
thoughts on vaught
it's our boy king eric voss
what's up hi i order u.s states by a
number of chipotle locations
um extra for guac but they don't have
freezers so you know everything is fresh
that has to go up every time we talk
about chipotle that's right it's true
they don't have razors ah the season's
over
it happened so fast tommy i but what an
ending
yeah i mean you know why it it
definitely feels faster because they
dropped three episodes at once because i
was like
this can't this hasn't felt like that
but wow
overall we're going to get into it but
what a season it's so hard to
follow up something that was so well
done i mean shows have such a hard time
piecing together multiple seasons of
solid solid programming this
to me this season of the show delivered
in ways that i thought were even
improvements on the first season yeah i
agree i totally agree
interesting places to go from here and
i'm so excited to see so let's let's uh
let's cover what happened
in the wake of the congress attack
schools are now showing safety videos
about how to protect from soup attacks
again another example of this show
getting so real that it's like
yeah ooh cringy the government is
preparing to give compound v to law
enforcement
butcher and the boys are arming
themselves to the teeth to fight the
seven
and becca escapes her compound and then
makes her way to butcher
in order to ask him to save ryan stan
edgar and aleister adana agree to let
the deep go back into the seven
a train finding out that he cannot go
back into the seven uh steals a file the
church has
on stormfront's nazi pass that actually
gives it to the boys uh gives it to huey
and starlight specifically butcher makes
a deal with stan edgar to get ryan away
from homelander
and hand him over to vaught but uh the
deal also includes becca staying with
him and separating from ryan so
uh an attempted betrayal for sure oh and
let's not forget
homelander and stormfront struggled to
raise ryan in homelanders image
tucking him away in a pristine beautiful
cottage right near
rochester new york that's right
homelander and stormfront had no choice
but to bring their boy to the flower
city and allow him to flourish like the
beautiful
super-powered orchid that he will become
and there's no better place there's
culture
there's industry there's sports i mean
presumably in a world without covet 19
of course
there's beautiful people walking around
there's the seneca park zoo
home of elephants and zebras and the
only place he can find those things i'm
sure
i'm told the only zoo left in america
and who else could forget
there's also batavia downs the greatest
harness racing track in the world
and other things follow me on my new
blog talk in chester
where i'll discuss all things to do in
rochester with your super powered boy
that you've kidnapped from his
mother anyway the boys released
stormfront's nazi history to the press
and shockingly everyone just believes it
they're like oh of course it's only
frenchy lures homelander away with those
deafening speakers which
sounded like they could really blast
some fleetwood mack so i i would be
interested in buying one
butcher can't go through with separating
becker from ryan so he lets them leave
together
while letting edgar's men face
homelanders wrath and that scene was
that scene gave me chills
when he realized that vaughn had turned
on him a little bit and like he was like
oh these guys are all dead
every time you realize they've made
homelanders so
powerful and rageful and deadly that
every time he gets angry i go this is
going to be so gross
this is going to be so awful uh yeah
yeah so
as ryan and becca are escaping uh
stormfront returns and
intercepts the car flips it over somehow
nobody dies from this which
i could see where ryan wouldn't die if
he's got homelanders dna
becca and mother's milk should
definitely be dead but
someone should have gotten more hurt
from that yeah yes uh
maeve then appears to help starlight and
kimiko fight stormfront and beat her
nazi ass
uh hey kraut was a great line uh
and the girls get it done as said by
frenchie uh great reference
yeah i gotta say way to come full circle
with something like it started with
making fun of avengers end game in that
moment that was a bit cringy and then
they turn it into satire and like we're
self-aware and now
by saying it they've made it sincere
again and showed that like
these things don't have to be cringy
like they yeah they can be really cool
to see
like yeah this was awesome this was
fantastic
stormfront flees uh and attacks butcher
and
becca in the woods ryan fry's stormfront
but also in that act
accidentally kills becca and boy did he
mess stormfront up i mean that was
kill me in german how do you say kill me
in german
[Music]
i don't know homelander catches up to
them but ryan wants to go with butcher
maeve threatens to release the flight 37
footage homelander does allow them to
leave shockingly
vaught blames the head popping on
stormfront starlight gets to rejoin the
seven along with a train
and the deep is now left out homelander
sends us all home by jerking off in the
moonlight
by himself i love that shot some people
say it was like a season one
shot that they weren't allowed to
include in season one but now amazon's
like whatever do what you want
but we got our lovely uh fap signal is
what i'm gonna cause
that was truly disturbing and hilarious
so ryan is then taken with mallory and
the cia
butcher and the boys are now working for
mallory's soup task force
which is kind of like how the comics
start out yeah yeah exactly as i said
this is this i'm still only on the first
um trade paperback of the
uh of the comics so i i'm still working
my way through it but yeah like this
seems much more
in line with the comics so that right
when we think that adan is about to get
a tax exemption
in exchange for more dirt on vaught his
head explodes pop
and we find out it was caused by newman
standing outside
and then in the next scene we see newman
exactly
hello donna so then
and then we're finally left with hughie
in an attempt to assert some
independence
going and getting a job for newman at
her campaign which is of course
perfect huey accidentally stepping into
the belly of the beast in an effort to
just do the right thing
and declare a little independence he
does the absolute
wrong thing so i mean like i said
an episode that ultimately gave us more
questions than answers but still felt
satisfying i mean
stormfront getting her comeuppance felt
very satisfying
yes again it's so funny this show that
is about
super powered individuals and giant
corporations
hits so many real life topics like you
know yeah
yeah it was uh it was insane like the
writing on this season was especially
sharp they uh
they didn't ever feel too preachy but it
felt like they were
uh a bit ahead of the curve or at least
with the curve when it comes to our
current political climate like they
understood it on a level that
i don't think any other show trying to
comment on our current political times
has had
yes aside from like you know uh satire
political shows like
fictional shows like they really nailed
it and uh you know i gotta say i did not
really see victoria newman coming and
it's because the show did not want us
like
the the effort the writers went to to
hide that reveal was
pretty extreme down to her whole
character development
there's a complete side to her that we
were not given a whole lot of clues on
there are some visual clues we'll talk
about but uh you would not have been
able to see those ahead of time
unless like you just made a blind guess
well it could be this character right
i think the people who predicted it just
made a blind guess that it was newman
based off of vic newman's role in the
comics yeah i i agree but i also
it was just so i was genuinely shocked
by it like i definitely yeah me too
had no that was not on my radar of
possibilities but um let's let's talk
about this i'm going to break down
um top 10 maybe a couple more easter
eggs visual details that you might have
missed from this episode let's start
with this big newman reveal
so what we learned about her she could
pop heads via line of sight her eyes do
glaze over white briefly afterwards
the show did a great job concealing this
if you do go back and look at that
congress attack from episode seven
every time a head explodes an angel gets
swings and
newman was looking directly at the
victim seconds before yeah so the
committee head
uh vogelbaum the the two more including
shockwave newman does this
subtle eye dart boom boom uh and then
it's immediately corresponded by two
pops
uh and then she's in her seat frozen
while she's looking at all the heads
around the room
but there's this amazing moment where uh
the pops stop
after mallory picks her out of her chair
but then newman turns
around to look at her chief of staff
having no reason to turn around to look
at her
and then the head pops i remembered it
being the opposite i thought the head
pop and then newman turned around no no
newman turns around first
looks at her assistant head pops and
then newman uses the shock of running
back to her
to sit back in that seat and pop even
more hits in the room
they're so messed up now i do have to
say it's hard to tell if her eyes turn
color during that attack
you can maybe detect the faintest
glimmer from her eyes right when mallory
pulls her up
um or maybe it's possible that you know
if you're in the room with someone
you're close to proximity no barriers
between you you don't
have to do that the eye wipe
with with adana she was on the other
side of a fence she was on the other
side of glass
maybe that was like a greater distance i
don't know we'll see
yeah but there's also another clue with
uh newman watch her closely during the
scene with secretary of defense
bob singer look there was no terrorist
it was vaught
it's a cool folks are scared
if vaught took a [ __ ] in the middle of
fifth avenue they'd throw a ticker tape
parade well of course that fifth avenue
line was a nod to trump saying he could
shoot someone in the middle fifth avenue
and get away with it
uh but newman if you watch is probing
the singer here she herself is watzku
from the inside of course
she's testing singer to see how much of
a political obstacle he'll be and when
he says for the record i agree with you
that's when she's like oh okay okay she
got her answer um
but my favorite moment is right here
when he says doses are going for five
million a pop
pentagon's got a big order in yeah
newman's eyes were glued
to singer but when he said the word pop
it nearly triggered her so she has to
like oh [ __ ] and immediately like look
away to take her eyes off his face
um tommy i feel like there's a lot more
throughout the season so we got a video
coming out monday where i'm gonna go
back through the whole season explain
each newman clue that we overlooked
because i think there's some really
subtle ones that
people still haven't really caught yeah
i just started re-watching
i've already found some some really cool
ones let's go back to the beginning of
the episode it opens with this uh
horrifying school safety video
it does reflect the episode description
on amazon's listing had a soup terrorist
alert
all caps um so this kind of bled right
into it i was like has the episode begun
yet are these like
fbi warnings real like um but the
teacher of course has
a firearm which is even more useless in
the real life proposals to arm teachers
since most soups are bulletproof right
but uh they use the acronym law
lock the door arm yourself and then wait
for a hero
two kids use the american flagpole tip
similar to how if you think about it
homelander is a stars and stripe
decorated
weapon of course he would love it if
they use that
um but lock arm weight comes back
throughout the episode uh there's one
moment with the vot soldiers where
homelander locks them
in with him then he arms himself with
his eyes charging up and then
he waits for them to tell him where ryan
is
l-a-w it's so creepy how it gets used
that way
it comes back later in another cool
moment we'll get to that in this
breakdown
okay there's another one where
stormfront and homelander talk about the
coming race war
don't worry silly frederick had a
solution for everything
a nod to the nazi's final solution but
also note the way she says
frederick once again her german accent
is coming out with names of people from
her past
and uh this in one of the cooler moments
of the episode comes up at the moment
she is fried by ryan
and uh she begins babbling in german
i'm shot in iron absolutely
now a lot of you guys were asking us
what she's saying we were able to
translate it to
quote it was so beautiful how the three
of us sat there
in the shade of an apple tree do you
remember the day frederick
chloe reached her arm out the window we
found the perfect spot at the river in
the shade of an apple
tree it was the first time chloe ate
fresh apples
yeah see stormfront's life is flashing
before her eyes and she's nostalgically
returning to this memory with frederick
vaught
and her daughter someone we know from
that moment episode seven that she still
misses horribly okay next detail there
are definitely some star wars parallels
with stormfront in the scene right like
she's using
lightning on billy and then she chokes
becca as ryan is watching not sure what
to do it's
very similar to the way the emperor is
hitting luke with that sith lightning as
vader's watching not sure what to do
until he finds his inner light
interestingly though
stormfront is the one who ends up more
like vader and anakin
like you know after obi-wan's high
ground her body
is burned and disfigured her limbs are
severed
to me i might be reading too much into
it it did kind of signal
that like vader with the emperor
stormfront wasn't the ultimate darkest
threat that we had to worry about this
season
head bopper newman is still out there
and poses an even scarier threat
a threat that i don't know about you
tommy but after episode seven
the whole episode ate every scene i was
freaking out
yes it's permanently stressful on that
show now
because there's someone whose power is
to make people's heads burst now that i
know that she has to be looking at them
i can kind of relax a little bit like
when they're in a basement somewhere i
can be like all right it's not gonna
happen here but yeah
sure sure um and then there's a scene
where ryan with ashley is eating tony
cicero's pizza that's the same italian
food chain where they kill translucent
season one butcher showed up at another
tony cicero's at the top of the season
but notice what ryan does to calm
himself
yeah i write down all 50 states as fast
as i can in either alphabetical order or
geographical order
this is similar in the comics to the
character soldier boy
who will sometimes list us states as a
battle cry
soldier boy has shown up a bunch of
times this season the statue in vaught
park uh he was a standy in the in the
pawn shop
he will join the cast next season played
by jensen ackles
butcher also told edgar that ryan was
his only possible contingency against
homelander which
is how black noir is kind of used in the
comics so i don't know tommy maybe
there's some kind of biological
connection between soldier boy
and homelander and ryan like maybe
they're all part of the same family tree
with each sun developed as a security
check
on their two powerful dad interesting
yeah okay a lot of you noticed the
subtle gust of wind on the fresca
napkins and the
in the church uh signaling a train had
snuck into eavesdrop but look closely at
the file that he stole from the church's
archives that is the church of the
collective seal and its logo
has a serpentine figure looks very
similar to the s
winding through the double triangles of
the scientology logo yes
now uh we know by now there's not too
much to the fresca other than you know
the colts kool-aid joke the the series
creator has said as much
and of course the amazing edit of adana
popping one open
leading to his head being popped and
there's a moment where stan edgar just
mentions how much he hates it fresh
crumb
no thank you awful stuff but then this
is so weird notice later when edgar
meets with butcher he drinks
this weird drink where it's just a
squirt of lime juice with it looks like
club soda
thank you alvin if you think about it
fresca's just basically
citrus soda it's really the same thing
but
i think this tells us that stan edgar
drinks the same kind of [ __ ] he's in the
same business
but he prefers the real thing as much as
he can like both he
and the church are really just in it for
the money but stan edgar only trusts
a real cocktail leading to that goal
that he can independently verify and
control he doesn't want something out of
a king
there could be more to that i just
thought that was a really cool like
character detail there
anthony starr gives off an amazing
performance this whole season but
there's this
really subtle micro expression when a
stormfront lectures ryan about white
genocide
they want to wipe us from this earth
just because of the color of our skin
really it's called white genocide
and we're gonna need people like you to
protect our kind so homelander is racist
no doubt but there is some daylight
between him and stormfront here see
stormfront's philosophy comes from a
sincere sense of victimhood
like that's how all fascist movements
start right like germans suffered after
world war one hitler made them think it
was the jews fault
today all over the world nativist
leaders are doing the same thing with
immigrants like all the bad things in
your life are the refugees the
immigrants fault the outsiders fault
um but homelander doesn't get that he
cannot relate
to victimhood at all he's superior his
racism stems from
ultimate superiority he looks down on
everyone
he can't relate with the masses at all
he's not afraid of any other
he's just a narcissist he's afraid of
not being loved by the masses
so i think this is just a little moment
telling us that
homelander was never meant to lead
stormfront's race war the way she wanted
him to
he could not be a leader of hearts and
minds he could not lead an army
he could not be part of a society he is
always alone he's like an apex predator
and i just think it's so cool how
anthony stark could telegraph that yeah
i noticed that as well that was great
yeah now my favorite easter egg this
episode i i think you might have caught
this on the news report revealing storm
fronts nazi origins the banner text
reads incredible lead thai stormfront to
jeffrey epstein's death
oh perfect you know unlike in our world
where jeffrey epstein of course was
killed by the zodiac killer ted cruz yes
of course
actually i do have a couple more i want
to go through real quick uh let's just
extend this to the top 15. you got it
yeah all right let's keep going baby
it's the end of the season
um so uh butcher gives ryan that saint
christopher talisman
uh that's the patron saint of travelers
and among catholics there's a well-known
depiction of saint christopher carrying
the christ child similar to how butcher
picks up and carries ryan
perhaps one day a christ-like deliverer
away from harm at the end of this
episode
uh just fun visual details that are
almost thrown away notice the boy's gear
mm has a snickers bar on the table i'm
wondering if that's a defense against
black mara with this recently discovered
nut allergies yes
uh and then frenchie's laptop is amazing
the back of it is decorated with the
french flag
and then when he closes the speaker app
you can see his desktop wallpaper is a
cat
with a tuxedo and glasses yeah awesome
wallpaper
and then during homelanders press
conference at the end of the episode
starlight if you notice is back in her
original wardrobe
apparently having negotiated out of her
you know new sexed up look that she was
forced to wear when she joined the seven
yes
and then speaking of wardrobe hughie
wears a shirt with fleetwood max rumors
which is in my opinion the best rock
album of all time
um and that is an album that was
recorded while the band members were
getting divorced they were
breaking up in their personal
relationships which seems to be
happening with huey when he appears to
leave the boys for newman's campaign
and the music that is playing over those
final minutes is the beach voice god
only knows which
also plays over the epilogue montage of
love actually which showed a mix of
happy endings and sad endings
yes but more importantly we learned the
origin of huey's billy joel love this
episode
somersault dance parties with his mom to
you may be right
and uh despite all that he still dances
to billy joel
um very interesting moment there yes um
but the track we hear in this episode is
only the good day young which if you
look at the lyrics of that song it's a
song about you know a good christian
girl who gets seduced by a bad boy and
earlier in the episode it seems to
reflect starlight she's a good christian
girl with a new cross necklace she's
thinking about her morality but really
the good girl learned to the dark side
of this episode is
hughie bringing us to our final shot and
this is the last detail i want to talk
about
uh huey takes a job working for newman
it's horrible i want to do it
the right way not covered in quite as
many guts oh poor huey now you're closer
to the blood splash zone than ever
before
poor guy but not only is huey the seduce
youngling to only the good day young the
final shot shows newman
darkly closing the door on us shutting
us out like the final shot of the
godfather but
this is another example of that cynical
safety video for the school earlier
law law as homelander did with the
soldiers newman
locks the door to trap you inside she's
super armed and now
we all have to wait to see what happens
next those are all the details i spotted
this episode we're again we're gonna be
doing another
breakdown of all the newman clues
throughout the season and yeah we'll be
talking more about the boys we can't
wait for season three
and we're gonna have some deeper
thoughts this episode but first we want
to thank some people who helped us make
it
all right everybody let's talk about
sleep so important
so necessary uh there are many reasons
why you might not be getting great sleep
right now
maybe your head just exploded when
you're opening a can of fresca
but your mattress should not be one of
them helix sleep makes personalized
mattresses
made in america ships straight to your
door with free no contact delivery
free returns and a 100 night sleep trial
and as i've said
if after 100 nights you're not in love
with this baby give it 101
you know give it another night these
things are incredible i slept on a helix
mattress last night i slept
like i was dead i didn't move i didn't
move a muscle i didn't roll around
uncomfortably i just laid flat on my
back staring at the ceiling
wondering about why we're here so to
choose a mattress helix made a
two-minute quiz that matches your body
type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
for me i just clicked a picture of a
hamburger and said i was a beefy boy who
likes to snooze snooze
eric you are uh a helix mattress owner
as well
yeah yeah uh tommy and i both sleep on
helixes sometimes the same one
when we need someone to hold but uh no
yeah it's like the helix uh lusk dusk
when i took the quiz it was like i'm
mostly a back sleeper until my
girlfriend's like stop snoring and then
i roll over on my side
yeah it's it's got like a good mix of
like different sleeping types on it and
they have different types for all kinds
of sleepers on belly sleepers whatever
you are they have it for you it's pretty
cool
and for me it's arms crossed i'm the
boss up at the ceiling
very revealing ah helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020
by gq magazine wired magazine and
apartment therapy and you know who else
made him the number one best overall
mattress
tom beck told okay official voice of the
buffalo bills just go to helixsleep.com
underground take their two-minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you with a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
you will love it
and they're not going to come back and
pick it up because you're going to sleep
on that thing
until the mattress literally
disintegrates ah
that's how long you'll have it for helix
is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
underground that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com slash underground for up to
200
off damn awesome damn
sleep is so important guys let's get
down to some deeper questions that we
all had coming out of this episode uh
eric what is newman's end game yeah
that's really the question right i think
obviously higher office she's running
for higher office uh
probably presidency she might settle for
the vice presidency and then
get the presidency when someone's head
accidentally pops um
but i think beyond that um i don't think
just the presidency is her end game i i
think obviously she's in cahoots with
vaude
as she's working with him to help drive
up the uh the price of their shares for
their company through their
pharmaceuticals and as we found out this
episode
it seems like in this world the
president has no problem bypassing the
fda
to get uh various pharmaceutical drugs
in people's hands including compound v
and if it uh if they can control the
market forces in that way they can
make a pretty nice windfall for both of
them and i think as
we saw with uh victoria newman i i she's
a soup herself and i don't think she's
really concerned with
whatever other kind of soup like she
would have secret service but i think
she's her own secret service
yes absolutely uh yeah i i would say
that we're being set up for
uh a lot more of we'll we'll find much
more of her agenda out after this year
or in season three rather i i uh yeah it
does because right now it seems kind of
like
why like i still have like why why did
she do all that like what's in it for
her
you know like i guess money would be the
thing but
uh yeah we will certainly find out
question two
is stormfront actually dead what do you
think tommy i mean we
she's messed up yeah she's messed up but
so was anakin skywalker
and uh i don't know it didn't seem like
we had a moment where you had that final
death rattle yeah it's just we started
to focus on other characters
in that scene and we know we know from
tv and movies especially in 2020
unless you see them dead they're not
dead they're coming back
like i mean she's coming back in some
way shape or form
whether i mean from my understanding of
when homelander was literally burning
her breasts off like she must be able to
regenerate to some degree right she must
yeah
yeah i don't i mean if it's lizard
reptilian where it's like she can
regrow limbs so there might be something
where she becomes kind of a cyborg
type uh soup yeah cyborg would be
sick i think if uh they wanted to show
her actually dead this is a show that is
no problem with gore they would have
like
ripped her in half the way that that
hitler cartoon did that was amazing
like i thought that was setting up what
was going to happen to her i thought a
car was going to hit her somehow
even though i don't think that would
kill her but yeah they wouldn't just cut
off her arms and legs
that's specific i think that's easily
replaceable by prosthetics especially if
you're soup
um or regrowable and i i think we'll see
her again she's too cool of a character
and that actress is so good yeah i have
cash it's amazing i'm wondering if maybe
we'll have a like
third faction like besides the boys and
boys versus vaught if there will be like
a
pro not proud boys but like maybe like a
white supremacist movement maybe we'll
find her
and like rebuild like you know rebuild
her or something like that
interesting to see uh okay question
three is there anything to the
disappearance of huey's mom
i might have just read into this uh too
much but it was just a weird thing in
that moment where
he said uh she didn't leave a note she
didn't call
nothing and he assumed that she left
right never turned back yeah i feel like
that's got to be a setup for something
with them
yeah too much time spent on it uh to
have it not
have be something that will be paid off
or explored again for sure yeah so i
mean
it would be a little like um ray
palpatine a little bit i think right you
know like
his what is so great about him is that
this one accident
with a train running through robin is
what drew him into this madness
right if there were some other kind of
mythology to his parentage
i don't want it to be that important but
it wouldn't be cool if it's like
personal like if his mom
was uh was like a whistleblower for
vaught or something like that
or something something else that's
connected to a lot well in the way
it might it might explain more of like
simon pegg's
kind of lack of motive where he said his
dad just stopped living life
yeah i could see that yeah um there's
like a lot of open-ended questions with
a lot of these characters which i love
like i love that mm has this whole thing
with his dad and we don't really know
exactly what his dad was
was suing over uh there's questions
about
black noir and what his identity is and
clearly these are all things that
they're saving for season three
next question do we think ryan is going
to turn evil eventually
that is kind of the question i mean it
looked like billy butcher was absolutely
going to kill him in that moment right
like
until homelanders showed up it looks
like uh
butcher didn't give a [ __ ] he was gonna
take him out but
uh here's what i'm thinking i think ryan
that's billy's concern that's billy's
expectation but
i think at the end of the day ryan is
gonna be our saving grace on this show
in the same way that like this whole
show began in a corrupt
messed up world i think it's uh maybe
seasons from now it's gonna end with
this thing like
we all worried that the next generation
would just get worse and we'd spiral
further and further down a pit of
despair
but really the next generation is our
shining beacon of hope we have to trust
these kids you know to save us i i did
agree with that logic that
you know ryan needed becca uh to
to be as good to avoid uh becoming
homelander but i guess the question now
is like
was becca's influence throughout these
early years enough
uh did she imprint enough goodness on
him it seems like he has a lot of good
traits
list states when he's feeling anxious
and uh
he you know he felt so bad when he
killed her and he inherently knows to
distrust
a homelander and trust billy butcher i
think those are all good qualities
yep agreed finally what's the deep going
to do now that his hopes of rejoining
the seven are dashed
oh i'm so excited to see the deep like i
hated the deep so much in season one but
he was so much fun to watch this season
yeah i hope they just keep getting
weirder and weirder with him like the
season they used him
as like the character to tie in this
whole church of the collective
mm-hmm i really want to see him like
become a sea
uh friend and just like spend all of his
time underwater yeah
or something weird like like maybe
starts like volunteering with kids
i feel like if you compare this to the
wire he could be the prez bellewski of
the show the presbyter is such a
[ __ ] at the start of that series
and then in season four he becomes the
coolest character when he becomes a
teacher
yeah and that was such an amazing arc
and i'd love to see the deep go on that
redemption arc and just become like
the most redeemed most interesting
character that we root for by the end of
the series that would be such an
interesting
yeah circle arc for sure yeah i'm
excited i could also see him becoming
like
uh a joel austin like kind of like
evangelical himself like you know be
wild like if he just like if he just
takes it even more like into like
the uh the cult like ultra religious uh
kind of full [ __ ] person uh anyway so
yeah it'll be fun to see what he does i
also yeah there's a version where if
he's just working at sea world that is
also very fun
uh and he's like doing this to the show
but uh or vaught land or maybe he gets
hired at a pod amusement park
anyway uh i'm gonna catch us up now on
the kill counts
for this episode and uh the final season
standings
for all of the murders and kills and
thrills and blood spills that took place
on the boys oh yeah the gill kills
ah so no we didn't see stormfront die
and we're told that she's in prison so
we're not going to
include her in the kill count but she is
definitely effed
as they say yeah also the big reveal at
the end of the episode obviously adjusts
our season totals so
more on that in just a second so ryan
has one kill his mom becca an emotional
kill
never ideal to murder your mother with a
uh
energy blast newman has one kill
alastair
donna that she uh popped his head like a
fresca top
homelander eight kills one vaught
mercenary on screen and seven off screen
we're assuming by the volume of the
blood on his face
that he killed the entire vlog team it
does not seem like there are any
survivors
when he came out with a like spa
treatment of blood and guts on him
that gives us our uh top five murderers
for the season top five killers
on this season of the boys we have black
noir with five kills at number five
we have kimiko with six kills at number
four
homelander coming in with 13 kills at
number three because he was
left at the last moment by congressman
newman our number two killer
with 16 kills after we found out she was
the one
pop lock and dropping storm front though
will be the all-time season leader
uh the season leader with 67 kills
that's a lot of kills
by a very bad person not a good person
speaking of killing it eric you killed
it all season what fun we've had
man this is great this is great marina
we missed you today that's our
show so great to chat with you all
season long eric this is our last boys
underground until next season
which hopefully we will get in 2021 in
the meantime keep your eyes peeled for
our coverage of the mandalorian season
two and one division both on disney plus
reminder to join our official discord by
becoming a patron at patreon.com
new rockstar you can follow me tommy
bechtold follow eric
ea voss follow new rockstar on socials
and subscribe here on youtube
to get too much information on all the
stuff you care about
let's go buffalo eric i bid you good day
bye tommy see you next time
[Music]
you